Southwest holiday travel nightmare is
not over the airline saying it will be
days before they are able to resume
their normal travel schedule and for
those stranded in long lines and forced
to sleep on Airport floors Southwest is
not bailing you out until Saturday at
the earliest as of right now Southwest
has surpassed 2 500 cancellations today
and over 2 300 flights already mixed for
tomorrow
but have no fear of Mayor Pete from
South Bend is on the case Transportation
secretary Pete Buda judge says he'll
come down hard on Southwest
everybody understands that there is
extreme weather across the country but
where most Airlines saw their
performance start to improve Southwest
has actually moved in the other
direction you've got passengers who are
stranded uh you got passengers who can't
get a hold of customer service it's an
unacceptable situation oh tough guy but
why didn't mayor Pete prevent this from
happening in the first place
Congresswoman Nancy mace is calling
for not not spitting up
it took four days and thousands and
thousands of cancellations for DOT to
finally speak up same thing it took four
days for the CEO of Southwest to finally
speak up I hope at some point the the
government when we are intervening and
looking at some of these issues that
were more efficient and more effective
but guess who didn't have to deal with
travel chaos President Joe Biden is now
soaking up the Sun and enjoying his
Caribbean vacation he did depart two
hours late but that was per his request
so all right Joey I'm going to start
with you Joe Biden doesn't care I mean
he's flying Air Force One all is Rich
climate friends are flying private what
can the government do anyway well that
is a question right what can the
government do
um we gave them I believe I thought my
research came up to like 4 billion I
guess it was 7 billion dollars just the
Southwest Airlines to keep their people
employed keep the planes in the air
through coven we know now with over 50
billion dollars into this industry uh
all these Airlines they let Pilots early
retire they let people take shorter
hours or ask people takes four hours
they really manipulated what PPP was
supposed to be versus what they used it
for and by the way I had some notes from
this morning Southwest made I think 1.72
billion in the first quarter that they
would not have made without that PPP
money and then the the CEO comes out and
he gives us apology that's about as
useful as a first-class seed on a
Southwest plane you know there's nothing
there no substance there whatsoever
saying we need to replace our systems
well you know what what about last year
when this happened yeah what about the
summer when this happened what about the
fact we've already paid for this and
here's the real problem with this what
Pete's going to do what may what
secretary Pete all respect given what
he's going to do is he's probably going
to work a deal to where we end up paying
to replace their systems for the good of
the people we just spend more money on
them that's what's going to happen that
is usually the government solution just
spend more money you make a great point
they could have you know upgraded their
own system they had the money to do that
at the same time Katie uh you know the
government put some really awful
mandates on the airline industry and a
lot of people left the the industry
because they were forced out because of
mandates and created shortages so the
government creates these problems and
then gets mad and and postures yeah when
things aren't going right yeah look I
think the airlines the way the way they
operate are infuriating right your your
bags one pound overweight they don't let
you take it but they're allowed to
cancel your flight and not give you a
voucher and you have to fight with them
about what the expectation is and all
that there's no flexibility in changing
your flight to a different day they
charge you however these calls for the
government to come in and do something
to change this problem especially with
someone like people to judge who
couldn't even fill potholes in his town
where he was mayor I think that he will
make it worse it was President Reagan
who said some of the most terrifying
words in the English language are I'm
here from the government and I'm I'm
here to help I think that they'll make
it worse that the government over like
regulates a number of these industries
and when Congress takes a look at this
especially House Republicans in January
with the new uh Congress I hope that
they ask the question about are there
regulations that are causing more
problems for the industry rather than
only looking at putting on more
regulations to prevent this from
happening in the future because as we've
seen the government over over regulating
in a lot of instances causes these
passive problems they should be looking
at both while also holding these
companies accountable because they do
get tons of taxpayer money so if you're
going to take money from the taxpayer
then you're accountable to the taxpayer
as well and representatives have an
obligation to make sure that the people
who are flying on these airlines are
represented that way Tyrus there are
stock markets Southwest Stock Market
their their value dropped by six percent
today so is the is Pete put a judge you
know scolding them going to be what
makes them change or is it the market
that's going to cause them to do what
Joey says and update their system and
make these changes here's the thing the
CEO knows that if it drops and they get
in trouble the government will step in
and save them again but we have to look
who does this really affect you made a
great point about there's no first class
on Southwest right so the chances are
there's usually a lower socioeconomical
class that are flying these flights
right exactly so sorry you know and they
didn't update their systems sorry that's
why you get the cheap flights want to
get away here's the cold part flights
are cheap though Tyrus these days
compared compared other ones they are
Southwest is cheaper you got to give
them that but here's the deal if and I'm
just maybe it's just but I'm betwixt my
weeks right now maybe but if they were
illegal immigrants stuck at the airport
buses would have showed up that's true
the United States government would have
found airplanes to fly him at night to
get them where to go so and the same
thing with the blizzard where were the
federal agents where's we don't see any
help from this Administration when
American people are in trouble because
voodaches could make some things happen
you can get some buses we can get some
stuff it might not be Planes Trains and
Automobiles there's hey it might not be
the way you get there but we'll get you
there because that's the American way
nope we'll let you know on Saturday in
the meantime just sleeping at an airport
for anyone who's ever done it not a good
time so I just it's such a great storm
out there we have paid for so many
flights and bus trips for illegals
throughout this
um excellent point Tyrus Richard I'm
going to ask you a sincere question and
I'm not saying this
year no no no no no
are Democrats Democrats had a lot of
Hope in people to judge are they
embarrassed of just how he's performed
over the last couple years this is not
even about people to judge though let's
be very clearly no hold on 90 of the
flights that have been canceled in the
United States is from one Airline a
majority of the flights canceled around
the world is from one Airline so to sit
here to blame this on the transportation
secretary when you have one Airline and
one irresponse it's not even the
employees of this Airlines
is 90 of the I did not interrupt you
ninety percent you're not answering what
time I said but but here's I'm making
stuff up and do it 90 of the airline 90
of the flights cancel the United States
today are from Southwest Airlines
because you have a bad management you
have a they have bad software you can't
blame the flight attendants you can't
blame the pilots you can't blame the
ramp agents you have to blame the people
who sit in the corporate Suites of
Southwest Airlines for canceling flights
period the end of story to blame Pete
bootage for the fact that Southwest
can't manage their place it's ridiculous
but I can't believe it for that but you
could chuck the response but could
exactly could they could they get buses
just like they do for illegals and move
people I mean I mean sure but once again
this is a this is about capitalism in an
airline that cannot manage it don't fly
Southwest Airlines good point hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else